there's new data from Spotify showing
just how badly our attention span is
crumbling you might have stopped
watching this already i'm only six
seconds in i think they have shown that
people are skipping songs to the point
of addiction to it let's look at the
research findings nearly a quarter of
all songs on Spotify get skipped within
five seconds of starting that's
basically 25% a quarter I'm not a
mathematician but it's going to do that
more than a third are skipped within 30
seconds nearly half of all songs are
skipped at some point so even if you
love your whose pop there with the kids
the Beyonce you're still skipping her
and teens show the most inclination to
skip but there's an increase for those
in their mid 40s as well I guess none of
this should be surprising right we're
all doing this all day long with our
phones and we're all tweeting and I
again I admit that I'm on this stuff all
the time but there's something I thought
interesting that it's related to music
now to like even music we're losing our
attention and our ability fragmented
attention I find that to be the case and
I and actually as you sent as i was
reading this story i realized i had a
video playing in the background then I
was supposed to also be listening to but
then I got bored and so I went over and
checked something else in I went oh my
gosh I'm doing it right now yeah yeah so
were you tweeting while I was reading
that I've no I was looking away were you
tweeting or facebooking there's a
different app involved there but yes
yeah uh yeah but I think just given the
opportunity to change what's happening
we're gonna take it right I mean how
many times did you listen to the radio
when a Nickleback song came on you were
like Jesus exactly through these you
know I would have skipped it before five
seconds was up and I think if you have
your playlist set up you know and you've
got songs that you you know select to
listen to maybe you just don't feel like
listening to it right then maybe we'll
come back to it and I don't know if it's
necessarily an example or a reason to
say like we're just so crazy and out of
control it's like works we're doing what
we what the whole point of the thing is
it's like to give you choice and you're
using your exercising your choice yeah
so I'm glad you went there immediately
cuz i do agree with that as a basic
principle that maybe this is just the
next step in this we seem to think
everything's bad you know everything's
getting faster and shorter and whatever
but i do think there's a chance that
maybe we're sort of we're allowing our
brains too
work on other things because you don't
because this short-term thing you can do
five things at once you can now watch a
video and you could probably mute that
video and have music on and be tweeting
and we're doing maybe we re why we've
talked about the rewiring of our brains
and maybe we are rewiring in a good way
is that possible oh I think absolutely
you know where brains our brains are as
humans we are so adaptable and our
brains are adapting to this new reality
that we've created for ourselves and you
know maybe the reason why we're
switching is because we really couldn't
before before you were limited playing
on the radio right then and whatever you
could switch to that might be
interesting or your cassette tapes you
know so we had the fact that we're
actually in a place now where we can
choose for ourselves and have this wide
menu to choose from on our own maybe
that's what our brains naturally always
wanted to do yeah well I didn't because
the you know the media didn't allow us
to yeah I mean doesn't mean any the way
it comes out elica liveries yeah let's
try and get it yeah well I think you're
right about the radio thing because this
past weekend I was driving up to Davis
it's from LA it's about a six hour drive
and I was doing the the radio thing just
FM radio and I realized how quickly you
I don't even know if it was five seconds
that I could hear a song and immediately
switch so maybe this isn't that new well
there's a lot more garbage music out
there first of all because I don't for
real yeah because it means to work in
music I was in a band you know it's a
lot easier to make music now it's a lot
easier to get your music on Spotify you
just have to basically pay 49 bucks and
it shows up there so it's like oh that's
interesting so just you just think
there's more garbage to Admiral so yeah
the level of you know the barriers to
entry have come down so much with the
advent of Technology recording
technology specifically that more people
are able to make more things if you
search for a song that you like on
Spotify you know let's use your favorite
Beyonce like you're just talking yes you
will find the be rightly I like Tina
Turner more but I was Wow well um anyway
uh if you find beyond now I'm off my
track thanks to Tina Turner you know
yeah riding on the freeway if you're not
not me uh if you look at at that Beyonce
song there's gonna be four different
cover versions of that by like local
bands from Idaho you know and and
they're not very good sorry so of course
you're gonna write so we've just made
the pool bigger and bigger I wonder how
much we can extrapolate from this but
killer study you know great that they
have all these metrics Expo defy that
they can actually look and say oh my God
look when they peek at this time of the
day radio did a modified indeed you know
and but as far as how much we can
extrapolate from that the actual
fragmentation of attention spans from
people i think spotify is very specific
because you know it is more hands-on
than just turning on something like
pandora the background on just letting
it shoes for you that randomization so
if it's more hands-on than it's going to
show more people are going to have more
fragmented attention because it requires
you to do that first part but you know i
don't know that that means that that is
necessarily one a bad thing and to that
it's happening really as much as this
specific study would indicate it may not
be that it's like that as much for
everybody it may just be that that's
because that's how spotify works best
yeah so I like that we're being pro
attention and anti attention here we're
giving it we're giving it both sides but
then I was thinking you know could we
ever have a classical music come back
where you know where you really listen
to one piece for 20 minutes or could it
could a bohemian rhapsody even ever be
written now you know because we're so in
this Katy Perry turned out as you said
you know like you now have these wooden
all these pop songs come out there's
literally teams of like 40 people just
coming up with some stupid repetitive
beat could we ever have sort of long
form music actually come back or is that
really a thing that that I think the
nature of how the music business works
today you know figuring out what the
formula is they have a popular song
you're talking the difference between
commercially popular versions artistic
yeah so as long as artists have an
opportunity to get their music and their
work out to a wider audience you know we
don't have the same system that we used
to for classical music you know if
they're able to still get it out there
then I think yeah that we will still
have a resurgence or the survival of
classical music and longer form pieces I
think so by the question sir yeah well
the good thing about having more
opportunities to get more music out is
that then as fan bases go they're able
to be segmented more so if you just
ended that one thing you can go and find
that the formulaic process of the music
industry has been going on since I don't
know 19
50 I'm sure I mean it's like you know
they look at a pop song man you look at
a pop song now you've got chord
progressions you've got beats that are
very much the same you're just recycled
over and over but if you're a consumer
you are no longer just getting your
music from the MTV's or around the radio
you know you can go out and if you would
like to listen to a cool train record go
for it you know do it or the new person
or Coltrane record whatever that is Tina
Turner in your case yeah well I wonder
how many of you actually watched this
entire video that would be I guess the
the ultimate lesson in this would be
that so let us know in the comments down
below